very pleased to see the business
secretary alex sharma
joins us in the studio sean lovely to
have you on the program this morning um
i suppose we had better start with
brexit just to just to change
from the norm as of this moment what is
it almost
at 20 past seven on monday morning
what's the state of the negotiations
well the state of negotiations is as the
prime minister said yesterday
is that we will continue discussing uh
we are of course a part on on certain
matters
uh but as the prime minister said we
don't want to walk away from these talks
uh people expect us businesses expect us
in the uk to go the extra mile
and that's precisely what we're doing
but but one point i do want to make neil
and i beat on
uh this program uh you know very
regularly over the past few years
and and um i've always said that
uh any deal that we get with the eu has
to respect the fact
that we are a sovereign country we're an
independent country and that's the basis
on which we will do a deal if there is a
deal to be done
but it's not we're not all being wrong
to be slightly more optimistic
about the prospect of a trade deal you
know this side of the weekend than
perhaps on friday
i mean the fact that can talks are
continuing suggests
there is the opportunity for progress to
be made even if the progress hasn't yet
been made
well of course we are continuing to talk
as i said i think that's what people
expect
and as the prime minister said uh where
there is life uh there is hope
uh but we are a part in in certain areas
so for instance the issue on dynamic
alignment
uh we've been very clear is that what we
can't do as a sovereign nation is to
accept the fact that if the eu changes
rules
we somehow have to follow suit uh so uh
you know fisheries
there are a number of areas that
discussions are continuing but of course
uh you would have seen the reaction for
business as well they're keen that these
discussions continue and we reach
a positive outcome still with every day
that passes now
until the 31st of december the pressure
on the government
actually security surely becomes greater
there are 17 days left
and businesses still as yet do not know
the trading conditions that they'll be
operating under in 18 days time
well so what i what i would say is that
actually whatever
type of relationship we have after the
transition period
there are change changes that are coming
and you know i've been writing to
hundreds of thousands of business on a
weekly basis we've been running webinars
we've been talking
through the the business representative
groups to millions of businesses
and making the point that they need to
be prepared for a whole range of things
that are going to change so for instance
customs arrangements will change
irrespective of whatever kind of
relationship we have if people from the
uk are looking to travel
to the eu after the transition period
they need to have a look and see whether
any visa requirements any work permit
requirements
there's a whole range of things that can
already be done by businesses but i
accept
i accept that um you know they want us
to conclude and that's what i hope we
will be able to do
indeed i'm just on that topic yesterday
i was speaking with the president of the
bcc
i mean pretty clearly they are they are
anxious that there's still not yet
the level of detail that business needs
need to be able to operate
for example on rules of origin on
tariffs this information
is not yet out there businesses can do
90 of the preparation
but you yourself know that in that final
10 could be the difference between
that business being successful that
business failing next year no and i
understand that but i think what you
will also have seen for instance from
the author sector the society for
motor manufacturers and traders uh in
response to the fact that we're
continuing
uh discussions they were pleased with
that and i know that you know adam
marshall and
and other colleagues at the british
chamber of commerce uh will also be
urging us
to go the extra mile which is what we're
doing um
reports this morning that the chancellor
is considering using
furlough and and other covert related
matters to help
businesses that might be affected by by
no deal in 2021
how accurate is that well uh you
wouldn't expect me to come on uh
your your program uh i thank you
absolutely you wouldn't ask me to
comment on that
but look uh of course uh you know we are
discussing all eventualities
uh we are having internal discussions
about all of these matters but uh you
know let's see where we get to in terms
of these discussions
uh we will of course have to respond to
any eventual answer
any eventuality at the end of that uh
and we discuss these matters internally
of course
we were talking in covert just after
this question but before that
supermarkets are apparently starting to
stockpile
is that wise business practice in your
mind right now well uh so i think you
know we we had
uh this same discussion during uh the
time of the first lockdown
uh and actually um you know people were
able to shop uh people were able to
to to to get uh uh items from shops
uh and so you know i'm very confident
that actually the supply chains will
still be in place
uh and um you know i would say to to to
everyone uh you know just do your normal
shopping as you would do
and i think we'll find we're going to be
absolutely fine um let's move of course
to to perhaps the
the the the most key element in the
government's public health strategy for
dealing with overnight
vaccination you know we're all expecting
news in the coming days about other
vaccines
coming on stream but in terms of that
which we have right now
are we any closer to being able to give
us a number on how many people have
received the vaccine the foreign
secretary couldn't do it yesterday
well i i think we'll have sort of tens
of thousands of people who've been
vaccinated so far
we we know that yes i mean i i think
that is the the case if that's wrong i'm
sure we will come back and
and correct that um but i think we we of
course
have a steady stream of the fisa biotech
vaccine which is coming through
this will depend of course how quickly
we can get this stuff manufactured as
you know
it has to be stored at minus 70 degrees
so there are particular manufacturing
processes
we've always said uh neil that the bulk
of the vaccination program will take
place uh early on next year
uh but of course the fact that we
started is very positive
of course gp surgeries starting their
role out today we're beginning to see
the vaccine getting into care homes as
well
just in terms of the infrastructure as
you say the of vaccine requires that
incredibly cold refrigeration to be to
be kept
viable how are we ensuring that that
happens in the care home settings
well so um uh you're absolutely right
that's been one of the issues here is to
make sure how do you get this stuff
across
so there is work that uh dhsc department
of health
uh has been doing with the mhra and of
course
you know those who are then supplying
this vaccine to make sure that that is
possible
um and you know as you said in in care
homes
uh we we will be making sure that uh by
christmas
uh people will be able to get this
vaccine a huge concern in parts of
london that infection appears to be
spiraling out of control
there is clearly a very real case
for london to enter into tier three now
are you minded to see that happen
well we have to look at the statistics
so um we've always said that we're going
to look at a number of key measures
infection rates growth rates in the
infection what is the availability of
health services particularly uh hospital
beds uh in any particular area
this week we will be looking at those
those stats and we will come to a
conclusion actually not just on london
but actually you know across across
england i mean there are there are areas
further north than here that could well
move from tier three down to tier two
all of this
remains under view but the reason i
focus specifically on london is this
morning
we are hearing that schools in greenwich
will be closed from this evening
now that seems to fly in the face of the
line that we have constantly
heard from the government keep the
schools open because
if they close there is a reputable harm
for children what are you going to do
about the situation in graduates well
so you're right and that is in indeed
the policies that we want to keep
schools open and i want to thank
actually all the teachers the head
teachers
who have managed to keep 99 of schools
open in
in england um we are ensuring that uh
home testing kits are available in
schools uh where there are
uh particular issues with infections
we're making sure that
the lateral flow tests are actually
going out to them and we will work with
local authorities uh on a case-by-case
basis but
overall message happy you can't be happy
with what's going on in greenwich that
the council leader there has
unilaterally decided to shut the schools
well our overall message is that we want
to keep schools open as you said
and actually we've heard this from the
chief medical officers as well over the
past few months is the fact that
uh you know for uh young people for
students
the best thing we can do to support them
is to keep them in education because we
know there are all sorts of negative
consequences when that doesn't happen
okay so what is the message to greenwich
there or
what schools what what i mean the
message to
uh overall message is that we want to
make sure that
schools stay open we will work with
individual local authorities and of
course
uh that discussion will be ongoing
obviously i'm not in the department for
education
of course but that discussion will be
ongoing uh to see how we can support
greenwich and indeed any other liberal
authority that comes forward we're also
apparently
this this is reported we haven't had
this direct from from the maid of london
himself but sadiq khan potentially
suggesting that schools
should close early this year i wonder
how you feel about that and
also about the mass expansion of
asymptomatic testing
in secondary school environment yeah
well i mean as i said the plan is uh for
schools to stay open
we think that's the best thing for
pupils and that's the basis on which
we're proceeding
is there a means by which schools could
be compelled
to remain open well i think uh
schools actually have remained open
kneel so as i said
you know 99 of schools have remained
open the vast majority of people
uh pupils have been going into school so
uh you know
we we want to work with schools we want
to work with teachers with head teachers
we want to work with local authorities
that's the basis on which we've been
proceeding and that's the basis on which
we'll carry on
just on just on christmas because of
course many people's minds some of us
are working on christmas i hasten to
point to
i'm sure you well i may be as well you
know me as well um but we heard from the
foreign secretary yesterday look that
christmas window will remain
open come walk me are you entirely happy
with that
just given given the the rates of
infection in various parts of the
country right now are pretty alarming
there will be a boost into infection
rates because of this christmas window
undoubtedly some people will die as a
result well we've taken
uh obviously a balance and proportion
approach this so we're talking about
uh you know three households uh uh
mixing during that period
and of course christmas is a time when
uh you know families want to come
together
uh and i'm you know yes you said you you
you'll be working who knows i may be
working as well but i hope
you know both of us have an opportunity
to spend some time with our families
during that that window
and i think it's right and it's it's
balanced and proportionate and as i said
that that is not going to be changing
whilst you have you and you can't leave
the studio once the cameras are on you
i'm going to be quite cheeky we've heard
from donald trump
uh that key people in the white house
will be first in line to receive the
vaccination
i'm wondering if there are any special
people in the british government uh that
might be jumping the queue
uh certainly not that i'm aware of and
uh i'm never someone who's
always wanted to jump the queue alex
shawn it's really good to see this thank
you for being with us